madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs j'ai
beaucoup apprécié effectivement les
interventions qu'on vient de le dire la
collègue victoire jasmin j'ai deux
questions qui demandent pas de réponse
longue alors une première question à
Madame Talbot sur le rapport sur les
inégalités de santé en Guyane qui date
du 4 mars 2021 avec comme grande
ambition de permettre à chaque femme
enceinte ou qu'elle réside en Guyane de
bénéficier d'une visite prénatale au
cours du premier trimestre de grossesse
nous savons que la surveillance de la
grossesse débarque souvent très en
retard en Guyane et empêche ainsi le
dépistage d'éventuels complications
médicales pouvez-vous me dire quel
pourcentage de femmes enceintes
bénéficient aujourd'hui de cette visite
prénatale j'ai une question aussi pour
Madame Aïssa touchambault j'ai eu
l'occasion d'alerter madame Charlotte
cobel secrétaire d'État en charge de
l'enfance sur la situation de l'accueil
des jeunes dans les familles
hébergeantes certainement des mesures
seront annoncées dans les semaines qui
viennent
de fois il serait intéressant d'avoir la
vue de Madame Chambaud qui est toujours
sur le terrain le réseau a mis en place
un dispositif pour couvrir
les soins des femmes qui n'ont pas de
couverture santé ça veut dire des femmes
qui viennent des pays voisins ensemble
et qui ne peuvent pas bénéficier de de
la couverture santé donc il y a un
dispositif de
consultation gratuite au niveau des
échographies donc c'est prise en charge
par le réseau de périnatalité question
de visite prénatale faisait partie de
c'était un point du contrat Protection
de l'Enfance entre la CTG ARS et les
services de l'État
donc là aussi on est confronté à la
pénurie de professionnels donc là
c'était j'ai pour être honnête a été en
incapacité de remplir cette mission
faute de pouvoir recruter
parce que le financement qui avait été
qui avait été alloué ne pouvait
permettre que
n'était pas dédié à financer des postes
existants c'était vraiment de nouveaux
postes du recrutement deuxième question
sur la les familles hébergeantes on
parle bien de femmes hébergères pas des
assistants familiaux donc le sujet est
toujours d'actualité
alors j'ai interpellé le cabinet du
président
cerner leur récemment là-dessus je sais
que c'est la collègue amirobos en
chow-chow qui a repris ce
[Musique]
ce dispositif qui qui va y travailler
j'ai pas forcément plus de de d'éléments
là dessus au niveau de la collectivité
mais je sais que le grand conseil
coutumier ça saisit de la de la question
et travail dessus depuis plusieurs mois
déjà j'ai une opportunité justement
d'avoir des réunions avec les
organisations autochtones et de grands
conseils coutumier alors là ce que il
faut en tout cas un dispositif
stable fiable une organisation fiable et
de financement pérenne il faut vraiment
il faut pas prendre le cette
problématique uniquement sous l'angle
des familles hébergeantes mais il faut
pouvoir proposer aux familles un
dispositif complet donc avec les
professionnels et avec autour
la différents acteurs donc il faut là
aussi de la conservation il y a quand
même il faut garder le collège jeune les
élèves gardent le lien avec leurs
parents et là se posent à nouveau la
question du transport fluvial et à
l'aérienne c'est vraiment la catast